never have I ever never have I ever
taken my penis and stuck it in my
[ __ ]
call that a call it a looky-loo what's
going on YouTube [ __ ] cute little ass
rashes that sounds really painful so
recently a subscriber asked David my
girlfriend said she doesn't believe I
could ever physically back her up if she
ever gone into a fight and that hurts me
[ __ ] pepper like it was playing with you
not really it's pretty [ __ ] up number
one let's just address this did she
actually say that in a dire situation
you would never be able to physically
back her up [ __ ] how big are you now
generally speaking I'm thinking in my
mind and since you are the male in the
relationship and this is a heterosexual
relationship then physically you're a
lot more bigger than she is or a lot
more capable if that's not the case
what the [ __ ] are you eating [ __ ] and
if you are physically a lot stronger
than he is the [ __ ] do you need him for
you know I have never really understood
this concept but it has to stem from the
fact that people equate manhood to
beating somebody's ass listen here
pepperoni nipples if everywhere you're
going and you meet another girl and the
first thing that happens is that you're
afraid that June again to a fight with
them maybe you're a [ __ ] no seriously
if you have been in multiple situations
in your life where every time you meet a
girl they want to fight you it's
probably not dead and you guys know what
I'm talking about you know those girls
every time you meet them they say the
same thing which is I'm a girl that
doesn't get along with other girls you
hang out with boys a lot because we v
better really [ __ ] it's funny because
every time I hear that [ __ ] all I seem
to hear is war I'm kidding it's not like
that
all the time but we do know a few of
those girls out there that keep saying
that when all they do is hang out with a
bunch of guys and then she dates all the
[ __ ] guys in that group yeah [ __ ] we
know your plan guys girlfriend if you're
watching this you probably already know
my mothership I just said there's a few
things that you just don't really say to
your boyfriend no challenge his [ __ ]
manhood you don't tell the guy even if
he's weak and scrawny or a large and fat
and you don't tell him that he can't
defend you that hurts him morally that's
like the type of [ __ ] that you say when
you want to break up with somebody you
know when you get into a fight with your
girl you guys break up momentarily she
just starts saying [ __ ] that she should
never say to another human being you
don't you just give a [ __ ] out of here
yeah I'm gonna get the [ __ ] on out again
[ __ ] your brother yeah oh really [ __ ]
thing if you're so worried that your
boyfriend can't physically protect you
why don't you just boost him up emotion
see baby why can't you go take us a
couple of self-defense classes because
we live in a very bad neighborhood or
you could just move out the [ __ ] hood
where do you live and it seems if she's
saying these type of things to you
honestly man that's very negative people
gotta learn how to talk to each other
very respectfully even if you feel
certain things about your partner you
have to learn how to phrase things right
maybe sometimes I feel like you don't
care about me and my physical well-being
I just need to know and be rest assured
that when [ __ ] goes down you'll be there
by my side look at that and you know
what what I said earlier I actually take
that back I hope she doesn't see this
because maybe you guys already worked
this [ __ ] out and then you know you
might get in trouble never get your dick
sucked
whoo it's hard suck in your own day hi
this is Kim Jong air speaking I just
want her to know that maybe you are
liking the video you saw subscribe and
give a thumbs up
if not go die last week you watching
videos about a yeast meet Easter it's a
number one dating site up or Asian
people remember daiba so always the best
North Korean never lose bye she they
called you ugly they said you had a
[ __ ] chicken nugget for now